I think the basic idea of loneliness of
the desire for love but the desire to
feel like he's Universal feelings and
especially in a small town where the
people are so isolated anyway and it's
such a small community
I remember when when it came out of
Italy was called multi most spectacular
so people in Italy and all around the
world it doesn't matter where you're
from you experience that the angst of
growing up the angst of growing older
well I think everybody relates to it I
got to travel with this film after it
was over I was asked to do a lot of
motion pictures I went all over the
world making films and in every little
village if it was in Yugoslavia or if it
was in Russia or some any little
hometown in the United States anywhere
anywhere in Europe it's the same story
it's the universal story every every
home town every little town has this
these people definitely you feel like
you kind of know those characters and
Texas kind of small town people but you
know I was from the suburbs in Dallas so
I can't say it was much like the
fictional town of an terrene but yeah
definitely the accents in the way the
town looks annoyed people dressed I mean
it definitely when growing up and going
to different ranches and farms should go
into these small towns and they did seem
kind of frozen in time it was before you
know kind of Walmart and things like
that so you really did still the time I
was growing up in the seventies you
really did that still have small-town
America I was in Stockholm and the
producer called me says we got eight
Oscars you were nominated for two of
them it was it I was extraordinary I
made up for the fact that I didn't mean
it didn't mean any more Bergman and I
was trying to me
32 is young but at the time I thought it
was I was behind the times
yeah I'm a big big fan of those Ben
Jonson scenes where he plays the
character Sam Malone I was very proud
that Ben Jonson got his award Sam and I
bought an old pickup truck and drove it
down to the Academy it at that time and
he came out and kicked the fender he was
the real he was real deal yeah John
Wayne said to me I can't show that
picture to my family Pete Jesus
definitely was influenced by it and
liked it yeah maybe like the first movie
I made with my brothers and Wes Anderson
I guess this movie bottle rocket might
seem a little like at about like kind of
guys in Texas and more kind of a
meandering feel but yeah I think we're
all definitely affected by it I mean I
guess if you really love something and
are interested in it then you're
affected by from 72 1980 was just a riot
like this it was a great great time when
you're on a wave like that you don't
know it you're just you're living it and
the best thing you can do is live in and
enjoy it every day Peter put back in a
scene where I'm seduced on the pool
table he put that back in and it makes
my character makes sense for the first
time because when you see me come back
from that date with my my mother's
boyfriend if you don't see the pool
scene where you see that seduction and
you see how cold he is there finally the
part makes sense to me but it took some
25 years or some 30 years for me to I
was always very uncomfortable watching
it I was the minute I was gonna come on
screen you know I get all tense and but
now I got relaxed about it it gave me a
career I'm very thankful of that
but I'm not from Texas I'm from Santa
Barbara California beach well I mean
it's definitely one of those movies
where it's just fun to watch because you
kind of recognize the landscape and I'm
from Dallas which is you know very close
to Archer City where it was filmed you
know when you see a movie on the big
screen it happens a lot out here I'll go
to different screenings and places and
see something I've seen like over and
over and you just can't believe how
different it is you know I find myself
like looking around the frame you know I
read a statistic the other day on the
Internet you read everything on the
Internet
that the last picture show is the best
reviewed film between gone with the wind
and the Godfather that's a long run I
don't know if it's true you can't
believe everything you read oh I like to
believe it's true
you